bien Monsieur le Commissaire mes chers
collègues nous sommes heureux de vous
recevoir aujourd'hui Monsieur le
Commissaire au Sénat pour une audition
commune devant notre commission des
affaires européennes et la commission
des affaires sociales qui est présidée
par mon ami Philippe Mouillet que je
salue bien sûr notre commission avait
déjà pu échanger avec vous en mai 2021
voilà la date qu'on cherchait tout à
l'heure mais en visioconférence en
raison des restrictions que nous
imposait la crise et la pandémie liée à
covid-19
nous sommes donc heureux de poursuivre
ce dialogue dans l'enceinte du Sénat sur
les enjeux de l'Europe sociale que suit
de très près notre commission nous
sommes au lendemain du sommet social de
valduchessse qui s'est tenu il y a une
semaine 40 ans après celui organisé en
janvier 1985 à l'initiative de Jacques
Delord dont je salue à nouveau la
mémoire et qui avait donné naissance au
dialogue social européen l'Europe
sociale reste un dé
d'actualité en effet les crises
successives quià traversa l'Europe ont
conduit à accentuer les écarts et les
inégalités sociales à l'intérieur et
entre les États-membres la fragmentation
du marché du travail qui participe au
phénomène de dumping social ainsi que le
taux de pauvreté dans l'Union européenne
se sont aggravés en 2022 plus de 95
millions d'Européens vivent sous le
seuil de pauvreté la construction d'une
Europe sociale représente ainsi un enjeu
majeur pour élever les standards sociaux
dans tous les pays membres de l'Union
européenne et contribuer à renforcer la
solidarité entre les peuples européens
notre commission des affaires
européennes s'est intéressé aux
différentes facettes de ce défi ces
derniers mois elle a appelé à un plan
d'action ambitieux pour donner corps au
socle européen des droits sociaux et
elle a notamment marqué son soutien la
proposition directive sur les salaires
minimaux pourriez-vous Monsieur le
Commissaire dresser le bilan de la
Commission européenne à l'approche de sa
fin de mandat concernant la mise en
œuvre de ce plan d'action s'agissant de
la directive sur les salaires minimaux
où en est où en éant de la transposition
de ce texte dans les États membres je
souhaiterais également revenir sur le
sommet de valduchesse évoqué
précédemment dont il a été fait très peu
de communication alors qu'il avait pour
objectif la relance du dialogue social
en Europe qu'en est-il pourriez-vous
nous en dire plus sur les principales
conclusions de ce sommet et leur mise en
œuvre concrète notamment pour remédier
aux pénuries de main d'œuvre dont souffr
2 tiers des pays membres de l'Union
européenne et des des PME
forcément nous sommes également désireux
de vous entendre sur un autre sujet
majeur sur lequel notre commission des
affaires européennes a travaillé dans le
détail la proposition de directive sur
les travailleurs de plateforme publiée
en décembre 2021 par la Commission à
l'initiative de notre commission le
Sénat adopté le 14 novembre 202 22 une
résolution pour soutenir la nécessité
d'un cadre juridique régulant le
développement des plateformes et
encadrant les condition de travail de
ces travailleurs dont le nombre devrait
s'élever à 43 millions en
2025 ce texte fait depuis plusieurs mois
l'objet de négociation difficile
notamment au sujet de mécanisme de
présomption légale de salariat qui
cristalise toutes les
oppositions d'après nos informations le
dernier texte négocié avec le Parlement
il y a quelques jours seulement
opérerait un changement total d'approche
concernant la présomption légale de
salariat il confirit au niveau national
la mise en place des mécanismes de
présomption légal sur la base des
principes généraux européens et
d'exigences minimal en abandonnant ainsi
le système des critères harmonisés qui
figurait au cœur de la proposition
directive de la Commission pourriez-vous
nous le confirmer Monsieur le
Commissaire ne faut-il pas craindre des
divergences entre les mécanisme mis en
place par les États-membres ce qui
inciterait les plateformes à rechercher
des législations les plus
favorable je souhaiterais enfin dire un
dernier mot sur un texte important
également en cours de négociation il
s'agit de la révision des règlements sur
la coordination des régimes de sécurité
sociale ce texte proposé en 2016 n'a
toujours pas pu aboutir il semblerait
que la présidence belge soit sur le
point d'abandonner l'affaire alors que
ce texte porte l'ambition essentielle de
lutter contre le dumping social au sein
de l'Union européenne Monsieur le
Commissaire quelle est la position de la
Commission sur ce texte son adoption
avant la fin de la mandature est-elle
encore
possible ces deux derniers textes que je
viens de citer font l'objet de
négociation ardu qui illustre les lignes
de fracture existant entre les
États-membres reflet de la diversité des
modèles sociaux Monsieur le Commissaire
comment surmonter ces lignes de fracture
qui sont final
autant de frein au renforcement de
l'Europe sociale peut-on être optimiste
sur la poursuite de la convergence
sociale au sein de notre Union
européenne à la veille d'un éventuel
élargissement qui verrait l'entrée d'un
certain nombre d'État au standards
économiques et sociaux encore plus
éloignés avant de vous entendre Monsieur
le Commissaire je vais laisser la parole
à mon collègue Philippe Mouillet qui est
président de la commission des affaires
sociales et qui va vous faire part de
ces sujets
d'intérêt merci monsieur le président
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Commissaire mes chers collègues à mon
tour je vous souhaite la bienvenue au
Sénat Monsieur le Commissaire et vous
remercie d'avoir accepté notre
invitation la commission des affaires
sociales est particulièrement attentive
aux politiques social européennes et à
la construction progressive d'un droit
social européen qui font que les
interactions entre le droit national et
le droit de l'Union sont de plus en plus
fortes notamment en matière de travail
de santé notre commission a eu par
exemple à examiner la loi du 9 mars 2023
portant adaptation au droit de l'Union
européenne qui a permis notamment de
transposer en droit français la
directive relative à des conditions de
travail transparente et prévisible dans
l'Union européenne je partage également
pleinement les observations et les
questions du Pré en Rapin nous serons
heureux d'entendre vos réponses et les
orientations de la commission sur les
questions des travailleurs de plateforme
qui a beaucoup occupé le Parlement
français récemment et je sais dateur je
crois que c'est ce soir enfin vous
rentrez ce soir pour traiter justement
de ce sujet
difficile j'aimerais également avoir
votre sentiment sur les enjeux de
coordination de régime de sécurité
sociale qui est aussi un point important
pour notre commission en complément je
souhaiterais vous interroger sur les
politiques d'insertion le Parlement
français a récemment adopté une loi pour
le plein emploi qui vise à renforcer
significativement l'accompagnement des
demandeurs d'emploi afin de réduire le
chômage les structures d'insertion et
les collectivités territoriales
bénéficient L lgement de fonds européens
pour financer sur nos territoires les
politiques d'insertion des personnes en
difficulté sociales afin des accompagné
vers l'emploi pourriez-vous nous faire
un état de l'application du du Fond
Social Européen plus qui est doté je
crois de 8 99,3 milliards d'euros sur la
période
2021-2027 et en précisant notamment les
principales politiqu financé et la
répartition des fonds entre les
États-membres et les sénateurs quient
les collectivités ici présents seront
forcément très à l'écoute de ces
informations les démarches pour
bénéficier de ces fonds sont parfois
lourdes pour les collectivités et les
conditions assez exigeantes des travaux
sont-ils envisagés pour faciliter
l'accès à ces fonds Monsieur le
Commissaire n vous remerci vivement pour
votre présence et maintenant je crois
que sous couvert du présent Rapin nous
vous cédons la parole voilà et je pense
qu'ensuite certains de nos collègues
auront peut-être des questions
complémentaires mais déjà le sujet est
déjà important à travers l'intervention
des deux présidents
merci VO merci
merci Messieurs les Présidents chers
membres du Sénat d'abord je je dois vous
faire part un peu de mon émotion d'être
devant vous aujourd'hui c'est pour moi
un très grand honneur mais c'est aussi
un très grand plaisir d'être auditionné
par le Sénat
français et c'est d'ailleurs tout à fait
dans dans la logique de la Commission de
travailler non seulement avec les
gouvernements mais d'être aussi à
l'écoute des des parlements nationaux je
crois que notamment dans un domaine
comme le domaine
social il est clair que beaucoup de
compétences
restent reste auprès des États-membres
sont des compétences nationales et donc
il est absolument indispens je dirais
même de d'être en contact et d'écouter
de dialoguer avec avec les les
parlements nationaux bien je je vais
tout de suite entrer dans dans les
questions que vous m'avez que vous
m'avez
soumise simplement pour vous situer le
travail dans quel esprit cette
commission a travaillé sur les les les
dossiers
sociaux
dès le départ nous avons eu un héritage
et l'héritage c'est ce socle des droits
sociaux qui a été adopté à gteborg en
2017 et qui contient d'une certaine
manière à travers les 20
principes les grands sujets de politique
sociale qui
effectivement sont à l'ordre du du jour
à la fois au niveau européen mais aussi
au niveau des États-membres ça va de
l'égalité hommes-femmes c'est le droit à
la formation mais c'est aussi le droit à
des services publics c'est le droit à
des négociations collectives le Sala
minimum et cetera donc ce sont 20
principes qui sont contenus dans le
socle des droits sociaux et cette
commission a voulu transformer les
principes en action concrète en
politique concrète et c'était d'ailleurs
l'engagement qui a été prise par la
présidente de la commission lors de son
élection de
effectivement de faire avancer l'Europe
sociale de renforcer ce qu' ce qu'on dit
la dimension sociale de l'Union
et donc on a travaillé sur un plan
d'action qui a été d'une certaine
manière entériné lors du sommet social
de Porto lors de la présidence
portugaise et euh ce euh ce plan
d'action contient d'ailleurs toutes les
différentes mesures que vous avez
énuméré et sur lesquel je vais un peu
m'étendre alors commençant peut-être par
la directive sur les salaires minimum
parce que c'est c'est un peu la
directive phare n'est-ce pas qui euh qui
euh
qui qui
marque ce mandat en matière sociale ce
n'est pas la seule mais c'est une
directive d'ailleurs qui je dois dire
n'était pas n'était pas évidente hein
parce que parler de salaire à l'échelle
européenne et de salaire
minimum c'était pas chose très facile
parce que les traités ne nous donnent
d'ailleurs pas une marge trop importante
sur les salaires et donc il fallait voir
aussi comment resta dans les clous des
articles du traité sur la subsidiarité
oui c'est ça vous l'avez dit le mot donc
de veiller à la subsidiarité en même
temps euh effectivement travailler sur
ce qu'on appelle la convergence
économique et sociale parce que nous
vivons dans une union qui est quand même
très diverse et très diverse aussi sur
le plan du du développement social et
vous avez mentionné d'ailleurs le
l'aspect de dumping social qui a été un
grand sujet qui reste d'ailleurs encore
parfois un sujet notamment quand on
discute de détachement on met en avant
cette question du dumping social et donc
cette directive sur les salaires minimum
a été inspirée par le fait que
effectivement construit un marché
intérieur on est pas pour tous les
États-membres mais pour quand
même une large majorité d'états-membres
dans une union économique et surtout
monétaire on partage la même monnaie et
quand on regarde l'évolution des
salaires et bien il y a des écarts si
on si on se réfère uniquement au salaire
minimum de 1 à peu près à 7 donc le
salaire minimum le plus bas qui est je
crois la Bulgarie au plus élevé qui est
celui pays que je connais assez bien et
qui porte le nom de ce merveilleux
palais donc il est clair que une Europe
qui doit converger 1 à 7 c'est énorme il
est clair aussi comme certains parfois
l'ont demandé il faut introduire un
salaire minimum européen bien impossible
quand vous avez une telle divergence
d'un ass de de dire il y a un salaire
minimum européen c'est pas possible
puisque d'abord on aurait pas eu le
droit en vertu du principe de sub
subidarité et du du texte du traité mais
aussi où est-ce que on aurait situé le
salaire minimum européen donc on a
choisi une méthode qui veut dire bah il
faut que dans chaque pays dans chaque
État membre les gouvernements avec les
partenaires sociaux d'ailleurs donc
l'idée de dialogue social est est
inhérente à cette directive il faut
essayer de de d'obtenir de fixer des
salaires qui permettent une vie décente
al ça c'est très g très gentil et très
généreux qu'est-ce que c'est qu'une vie
décente bon on a introduit indirectement
des critères qui sont des critères
d'ailleurs acceptés internationalement
qui sont euh 60 % du salaire médian
parce que c'est là où on situe le niveau
de pauvreté aussi et où 50 % du du
salaire moyen donc voilà les les les je
dirais les les les les les éléments qui
doivent inspirer les États-membres quand
il s'agit de fixer le salaire minimum
bon il s ajoute que effectivement il y a
d'autres critères comme l'acceptation de
l'indexation en France le SMIC est
indexé donc c'est c'est accepté ce qui
n'est pas pour la commission une chose
une mince affaire puisque pendant très
longtemps la commission était plaidée
toujours pour la désindexation des
salaires donc on dit mais les États qui
indexent le salaire minimum c'est c'est
la bienvenue c'est c'est tout à fait une
possibilité mais euh donc maintenant
vous m'avez dit cette directive a été
adoptée à la majorité qualifiée il y a
eu quelques États qui se sont prononcé
contre euh il y a un petit problème qui
reste en suspens parce que deux pays je
crois il y en a que deux ont porté la
directive devant la Cour de justice en
disant là euh vous déviez un peu par
rapport à vos compétences et on attend
maintenant je dois tout vous dire on
attend maintenant le jugement de la Cour
de justice pour dire soit on a respecté
parce que c'était un grand sujet nos
compétences en la matière euh ou
éventuellement non parce que la
directive sur les salaires minimum n'est
pas uniquement une directive sur les
salaires minimums et j'y insiste
beaucoup parce que en fait c'est une
directive qui va au-delà qui euh euh
parce que le salaire minimum c'est très
bien j'ai entendu le Premier ministre
récemment parler de la
desmikication de la France oui c'est le
problème que quand trop de gens sont au
SMIC au salaire minimum c'est pas
nécessairement une bonne chose et donc
on juge que certes il est important
d'avoir des salaires minimum décent
d'avoir un niveau de salaire qui permet
effectivement une vie décente mais il
faut surtout une une fixation de salaire
qui est basée sur dialogue social et en
fait sur la négociation collective et
donc la deuxième partie qui est
peut-être au moins aussi important que
la première de cette directive c'est une
invitation aux États-membres alors
peut-être moins à la France puisque vous
avez une couverture très large par les
conventions collectives mais à d'autres
États-membres notamment des des États
qui ont rejoint l'Union un peu plus plus
plus tardivement où le niveau de
couverture par des conventions
collectives est extrêmement basse et
donc on juge que dans une économie
sociale de marché en fait les salaires
devraient être non pas fixés par l'État
à travers un salaire minimum mais
devrait largement être fixé par la
négociation collective entre employeur
et et salariés entre employeur et
syndicat et donc ça c'est un élément
important qu'il faut aussi transposer
qui prévoit un certain nombre de
principes sur les droits des partenaires
sociaux dans les négociations
collectives et qui fixe un un seuil qui
n'est pas un seuil je dirais légal mais
qui est quand même un seuil ind
indicatif qui est une couverture par des
conventions collectives de 80 %. 80 %
c'est beaucoup euh pour beaucoup de pays
c'est beaucoup donc les États devraient
tendre vers une couverture à 80 % il y a
quelques pays qui atteignent ce niveau
bien sûr les pays nordiques qui n'ont
d'ailleurs pas de salaire minimum faut
le dire la Suède ni la Suède ni le
Danemark ni la Finlande la Norvège aussi
mais elle est pas membre de l'Union ni
l'Autriche d'ailleurs non de salaire
minimum parce que tout se règle à
travers des conventions collectives et
donc nous voulons encourager les autres
États-membres à travailler sur une
extension des convention collective en
en améliorant
aussi le dialogue social et en mettant
bien sûr les les partenaires sociau
ensemble pour atteindre cet objectif
donc ça c'est un aspect aussi qui qui
fait partie de la directive alors sur la
transposition elle elle est toujours en
cours puisque d'abord il y a ce petit
problème de la Cour de justice que j'ai
mentionné et euh bien sûr les la
directive devra être transposée en en
novembre de cette année donc il y a
encore un peu d'espace pour la
transposer donc voilà ces directif qui
est importante et qui montre
effectivement dans union où
effectivement il y
a beaucoup de choses qui nous lient
notamment un marché intérieur la
mobilité et cetera donc où effectivement
aussi le social et les salaires doivent
être partie intégrante tout en
respectant monsieur le Président la
subsidiarité doit être prise en
considération voilà ça c'est mon point
sur la directive s sur le sommet de Val
duchasse je crois que vous avez bien
fait l'historique du sommet de Val du
chasse et je dirait que ça se situe un
peu dans la même logique parce que nous
sommes actuellement dans une période
transformation incroyable profonde dans
tous les domaines on voit d'ailleurs il
y a des catégories
sociale économique qui sont pas
contentes puisque on les voit dans dans
dans nos dans nos rues en Europe partout
euh mais bien sûr il y a des secteurs
qui sont impactés plus que d'autres par
tout cette par toute cette
transformation qui est en cours qui est
à la fois bien sûr la transformation d
au changement climatique et donc à ce
qu'on appelle le greind deal j'ai pas de
vraiment de traduction française pour ça
mais tout le monde le comprend et mais
d'un côté et de l'autre côté le monde du
travail mais aussi le monde économique
qui est en pleine transformation parce
que les technologies que auxquelles nous
sommes maintenant confrontés je dirais
quotidiennement évoluent très vite et
massivement c'est bien sûr la
l'intelligence artificielle c'est la
robotisation et cetera et cetera donc
les entreprises doivent suivre cette
évolution les secteurs doivent suivre
cette évolution
je donne toujours comme exemple
notamment un grand secteur qui reste
aussi un grand secteur en Europe avec 14
millions d'employés c'est le secteur de
l'automobile hein 14 millions d'employés
qui est en pleine transformation vers du
moteur à explosion vers le moteur
électrique alors un moteur électrique
moi je suis pas très technicien mais
quelque chose de fondamentalement
différent par rapport au moteur à
explosion moins de
pièces donc les sous-traitants de
l'industrie automobile vont être
impactés par ces changements
fondamentaux comment est-ce qu'on va
gérer cela comment est-ce qu'on va
mettre en œuvre ça parce que grosso modo
les lignes sont fixées par le Green Deal
hein les lignes plus les réglementations
sont définies maintenant il s'agit de
mettre en œuvre et c'est la mise en
œuvre d'ailleurs qui est la plus la plus
dure parce que c'est là où il faut dans
la réalité
transposer des règles et euh euh qui
sont nécessaires si on veut atteindre
notre objectif qui est zéro émission
émission de CO2 à l'horizon 2050 on a
d'ailleurs hier
euh fixé un objectif intermédiaire en
2040 on veut atteindre 90 % donc
maintenant il faut se concentrer sur la
mise en œuvre et la mise en œuvre
implique des adaptations fortes dans
beaucoup de secteurs y compris
d'ailleurs au niveau des personnes au
niveau de nous-mêmes de nos ménages et
donc comment est-ce qu'on va gérer tout
cela et donc valduchess c'est un signal
que on doit mettre en œuvre tout cela
dans une dans un cadre de dialogue
social juste un mot de lor vous avez
cité le président de l'or quand il a
lancé le le le la conférence sociale de
Vald chass d'ailleurs 39 ans il y a 39
ans euh bon il y avait c'est son grand
projet à
l'époque c'était le marché intérieur
c'était le marché intérieur et il avait
compris que on pouvait pas la mettre en
œuvre un tel projet qui lui aussi allait
bouleverser un certain nombre de
secteurs puisqu'il sit s'agissait
précisément d'accélérer et de
d'amplifier les échanges au sein même de
ce qu'on appelait à l'époque la
Communauté européenne il fallait
associer les partenaires sociaux à ces
changements donc lui d'ailleurs déjà
auparavant dans ses fonctions de
ministre mais aussi de conseiller de du
Premier ministre Chavant Delmas il était
le grand défenseur du dialogue social
hein et et donc c'était l'idée de de
l'or et on on a un peu repris cette idée
pour accompagner le euh euh le les les
les grandes transformations en cours ou
à réaliser dans dans dans les années à
venir donc le sommet de valuchess n'est
pas un sommet qui a produit maintenant
des résultats concrets pour le moment
mais qui nous donne en quelque sorte une
feuille de route comment l'Europe doit
mieux associer les les parties prenantes
et surtout je dirais principalement les
les partenaires sociaux pour
effectivement rendre aussi acceptable
d'ailleurs ces changements parce que les
imposés je crois pas que c'est une
option on le voit et donc il faut rendre
acceptable intelligible et tout cela on
doit le réaliser dans un contexte de
dialogue social donc c'est améliorer le
dialogue social entre d'ailleurs la
Commission et les partenaires sociaux au
niveau européen mais ça vaut aussi pour
les États-membres parce qu'on a
d'ailleurs la commission finalement le
Conseil puisque c'est une recommandation
du Conseil a adopté une ation sur le
dialogue social qui incite les
États-membres à améliorer le dialogue
social à tous les niveaux bien sûr au
niveau national mais aussi au niveau des
entreprises donc tout cela se se
s'intègre tout cela doit être vu comme
un ensemble que effectivement on met au
cœur même de de ce changement
fondamental le dialogue social
et pour effectivement mieux
réaliser ceses ces changements ça veut
dire aussi que bien sûr il y a des
sujets qui se traitent mieux dans un
contexte de dialogue social que sans et
vous avez mentionné la pénuie de main
d'œuvre et je crois que ça c'est un
grand sujet dans tous les États-membres
là où je vais même ceux bon la France a
un tau de chômage qui est un peu
auudessus de la moyenne qui qui a baissé
mais qui est quand même légèrement
au-dessus de la moyenne européenne
même dans les pays où le taux de chômage
est encore supérieur il y a le sujet la
pénie de main d'œuvre pénuie de main
d'œuvre dans certains secteurs qui sont
particulièrement affectés alors c'est
souvent pénuie de main d'œuvre très
qualifié alors bien sûr chacun cherche
les
spécialistes de la des technologies de
l'information et cetera mais il y a
aussi pénorie de main d'œuvre pour
la restauration surtout après le covid
il y a la pénuie de main d'œuvre dans
tout ce qui est soin à la fois
hospitalier et cetera donc de voir un
peu quelle est la situation de de de de
nos notre main d'œuvre en Europe al il
faut savoir que chaque l'Europe perdra
dans l'avenir chaque année chaque année
1 million 1 million de de de de
personnes qui potentiellement de -être
dans l'emploi 1 million en moins chaque
année pour des raisons évidentes c'est
l'évolution démographique donc comment
est-ce qu'on va gérer cette cette
réduction de notre main d'œuvre euh et
comment est-ce que aussi on va qualifier
parce que quand je dis 7 % de chômeurs
ou plus en Espagne et cetera comment
est-ce qu'on va qualifier mieux notre
main d'œuvre parce que pour pour moi la
priorité c'est bien sûr de voir quelles
sont les ressources que nous avons sur
le marché du travail qui ne s'intègrent
pas facilement sur le marché du travail
donc ça c'est le volet emploi que vous
m'avez demandé de peut-être de traiter
comment est-ce qu'on va
lancer une politique d'activation d'une
politique de formation à la fois des
jeunes l'apprentissage en est d'ailleurs
un élément important je je je ne manque
jamais de dire que là je crois que la
France a a a fait des progrès énormes
sur l'apprentissage quand je le compare
au passé quand je compare à d'autres
États donc là il y a il y a des progrès
sur l'apprentissage mais le le grand
thème c'est la la la la qualification et
surtout aussi la
requalification parce que si nous
parlons de transitions économiques
notamment verte mais aussi enfin tout ce
qui touche au au numérique bien nous
savons que nous devons requalifier un
certain nombre de travailleurs ceux qui
perdent leur emploi ou ceux qui voient
leur emploi même dans chaque entreprise
changer donc c'est d'ailleurs pour cette
raison que la Commission a proposé
décidé avec le le Parlement européen et
le Conseil euh de de déclarer l'année
euh 23 et 24 c'est un peu à cheval sur
les deux années l'Année européenne des
compétences donc de donner un signal et
c'est très deorien aussi parce que de
l'or était très porté sur la la
formation continue d'ailleurs il a fait
en France la première grande loi
européenne je dirais en Europe sur la
formation continue comment est-ce qu'on
agence mieux la formation continue
comment on réalise mieux le droit à la
formation la France d'ailleurs a
instauré le fameux compte personnel ou
compte individuel de formation qui qu'on
a transformé à l'échelle européenne en
une recommandation en en incitant les
autres États-membres à copier l'exemple
donc ça c'est la grande politique de de
formation d'activation d'insertion dans
euh l'emploi vous m'avez demander sur le
fond social européen oui ça c'est un
élément essentiel du Fond Social
Européen à peu près 20 % si je me
rappelle bien maintenant j'ai pas les
chiffres je je les ai pas je crois ici
mais je peux vous les envoyer euh
sont alloués à la formation de à la
formation à la formation et à
l'insertion professionnelle c'est ça
vaut pour les jeunes parce que nous
avons malheureusement encore en Europe
beaucoup de jeunes au chômage le
problème des nits c'est-à-dire les
jeunes qui sont ni en emploi ni en
formation ni à l'école représente dans
beaucoup de pays y compris un peu en
France d'ailleurs soyons franc un
problème donc il faut je crois doubler
d'effort pour permettre aux jeunes
d'acquérir d'abord une formation
appropriée pour ceux qui peut-être ont
une formation mais qui ne trouvent pas
de débouché sur marché du travail et
qu'il faut peut-être requalifier ou pour
ceux qui n'ont ceux qui ont quitté
l'école prématurément et cetera donc je
crois que ça c'est un élément central du
Fond Social d'investir dans les
compétences d'investir dans l'activation
sur le marché du
travail
sur peut-être maintenant je
passe au oui
[Musique]
au au à la à la directive sur les les
plateformes là je suis un peu en
difficulté parce que nous sommes en
plein dans la négociation donc je peux
pas malheureusement je peux pas vous
dire oui c'est bon on a trouvé un accord
puisque
actuellement nous sommes en contact
minute par minute ce qui se passe à
Bruxelles puisque on discute maintenant
sur un compromis au Conseil hein parce
que nous sommes maintenant arrivés à un
stade où c'est entre le Conseil et le
Parlement donc ce qu'on appelle le
trilogue mais en fait c'est plus un
dialogue voir une une négociation à deux
où la commission accompagne donne son
avis peut effectivement aussi
théoriquement bloquer mais bien sûr on a
intérêt à à ce que un un compromis
émerge bon pourquoi est-ce que c'est si
important bon je crois que c'est c'est
important pour par le simple fait que il
est inadmissible que des millions et
vous avez je crois vous avez cité les
chiffres des millions de de de
travailleurs en Europe un peu
partout ne soi pas couverts ou
insuffisamment couvert par les droits
sociaux par le droit du travail qu'on
considère quand même comme des droits de
base ça c'est un premier point le
deuxème point point c'est
que si vous avez un secteur qui
fonctionne sur base de plateforme ce qui
veut dire en fait sur base d'algorithme
parce que les plateformes c'est
l'utilisation
d'algorithme où finalement vous
contournez le droit social le droit du
travail simplement en créant parfois une
fiction
d'entrepreneuriat parce que on va vous
dire mais moi je suis une plateforme je
suis pas un employé
et toi tu n'es pas un salarié tu es un
entrepreneur bon CER j'ai un vélo
peut-être une voiture peut-être une
motocyclette mais en fait je suis
extrêmement dépendant de la plateforme
pour plein de choses donc il y a une
sorte de fiction de d'entrepreneuriat ce
qui veut pas dire que il y a des vrais
indépendants aussi qui travaillent pour
les
plateformes je dis nous ne disons pas
dans notre proposition tous ceux qui
travaillent pour les plateformes sont
obligatoirement et automatiquement des
des travailleurs des salariés nous
disons il faut regarder si effectivement
il y a un lien de subordination il y a
pas de raison pour ne pas conclure à un
rapport de salarié de salarié à
employeur et ça c'est le grand débat
comment est-ce qu'on définit le statut
donc le statut des des travailleurs
puisque malheureusement ou en
logiquement
au statut de travailleur sont attachés à
un certain nombre de droits qui sont pas
nécessairement attachés au statut
d'indépendant alors bien sûr on peut
avoir des catégories intermédiaires
c'est un peu l'option que la France a a
ébauché je dirais mais il est important
d'avoir clarté clarté partout en Europe
parce que dans certains pays les
plateformes sont jugées être des
employeurs dans d'autres c'est le
contraire donc de créer quand même une
sorte de de de minimum de de standard
minimum à l'échelle de l'Europe et c'est
ça le le un des points essentiels et ce
qu'on a choisi comme méthode c'est la
présempption c'est-à-dire que s'il y a
un doute sur base de critères mais les
critères européens ont maintenant
disparu en faveur de critères que chaque
État membre peut définir lui-même très
bien si ça ça permet de conclure
positivement je suis je suis d'accord et
le seul point c'est la présomption c'est
que auparavant c'était au au
travailleurs de la plateforme de
démontrer qu'il n'était pas un
indépendant mais qu'il
était un un un salarié maintenant on a
renversé la charge de la preuve c'est
d'ailleur s'il y a des arguments qui
plaident en faveur du statut de salarié
c'est à la plateforme après d'avoir le
droit bien sûr de démontrer le contraire
donc c'est le renversement de la charge
la preuve basée sur une présempption qui
si elle est vérifiée sur base de
critères maintenant plutôt nationaux on
ont conclut au statut de salarial au
statut salarial donc c'est c'est ça
l'essentiel et et donc si on conclut que
effectivement les conditions sont
remplies on on va reclassifier le le
travailleur donc c'est ça l'essence plus
bien sûr une définition de ce que
l'algorithme peut faire ne peut faire
pas faire donc les droits des des
travailleurs des plateformes par rapport
au fonctionnement de l'algorithme là
c'est important parce que c'est
finalement l'économie de l'avenir he
l'algorithme sera non pas uniquement
utilisé dans les plateformes
l'algorithme les algorithmes s'étendent
à tous les niveaux notamment au niveau
aussi de la gestion des ressources
humaines beaucoup d'entreprises aux
États-Unis maintenant considère que 70 %
des entreprises à partir d'un certain
seuil utiliseent les algorithmes pour
gérer leur personnel donc c'est
important aussi pour garantir les droits
voilà euh mon dernier je dirais euh mon
dernier point que vous m'avez euh euh
soumis c'est le règlement
883 qui est un règlement avec différents
éléments tous les éléments sauf deux ont
été adoptés ou agréés pas adopté agréé
donc c'est les droits notamment en terme
de des travailleurs en terme de de soins
quand je suis dans un autre étatmembre
de soins et cetera tout ça c'est agréé
il y a reste deux points c'est le point
chômage paiement des indemnités de
chômage la question très difficile à la
fois entre parlements mais aussi entre
États-membres qui paye à partir de quand
les allocations de chômage question qui
n'est pas résolue parce que certains
veulent pas d'autres veulent très vite
donc ça c'est un point de désaccord et
le deuxième point et vous l'avez suggéré
c'est
quel contrôle pour les pour les
travailleurs détachés parce que
effectivement maintenant en un contrôle
mais le Parlement puisque ça c'est
quelque chose qui a été introduit par le
Parlement pour renforcer le contrôle
donc il faut une sorte de contrôle
préalable avant que le salarié détaché
commence son travail dans le pays vers
lequel il est détaché de d'avoir la
possibilité de de contrôler ça
auparavant bon pour voir s'il est
effectivement assuré s'il a une sécurité
sociale dans le pays dont il
provient problème là aussi entre des
interprétations différentes divergentes
des exemptions qu'est-ce qu'on fait dans
les régions frontalières et cetera donc
ça ce sont les deux points qui restent à
résoudre et qui sont très difficiles à
résoudre parce que les États euh les
intérêts des états divergent évidemment
beaucoup il y a les États qui ont
beaucoup de frontaliers qu'ils envoient
vers l'extérieur ils aimeraient bien sûr
que l'état où vont les frontaliers Assur
les les les allocations de chômage
et il y a des États qui veulent aussi
faciliter les contrôles en matière de
détachement donc en en gros c'est ça ça
d'ailleurs la présidence belge d'après
ce que j'ai appris a abandonn maintenant
le dossier elle va pas poursuivre elle
voulait cinder euh le le règlement tout
ce qui était agréé le faire adopter mais
le Parlement n'est pas prêt à accepter
cela voilà enfin je suis pas sûr si j'ai
répondu à tout mais c'était déjà fort
longtemps oui
voil on va passer la la parole à nos
collègues alors il y en a qui sont
affaires sociales européennes je vais
passer la parole tout de suite à audre
lineneld merci monsieur le Président
bonjour AEL sénatrice du Nord d'abord un
mot pour dire que je me réjouis même si
ça n'est pas encore fait de l'avancement
de de la discussion sur les plateformes
je me souviens d'une autre époque où euh
euh j'étais à l'époque parlementaire
dans dans une autre chambre du Parlement
français à l'Assemblée nationale et
c'était contre un certain ministre de
l'Économie devenu aujourd'hui président
de la République que j'essayé en vain de
faire adopter des amendement pour
réguler les plateformes en France donc
tant mieux si plusieurs années après ce
sujet avance y compris à l'échelle
européenne et j'espère que ça n'est donc
pas le même qui bloque encore les
avancées que vous essayez d'obtenir ceci
étant préciser ma question porte sur un
un autre sujet nous sommes en France
très durement touchés par une crise du
logement liée à une pénurie très forte
de logement de toutes sortes euh
évidemment d'abord de logement abordable
en location en accession euh je ne ferai
pas de commentaire ici sur la manière
dont dont je pense que cette crise
pourrait être surmonté à l'échelle
nationale ma question porte plutôt sur
l'échelon européen quel est le regard
que vous portez sur cette question du
logement puisque vous avez fait
référence au socle euh des des des
droits sociaux le logement et l'aide au
sansabri en font partie de ces 20
principes je crois qu'aujourd'hui la
situation du logement est est difficile
ailleurs aussi et j'aimerais donc avoir
le regard du commissaire que vous êtes
sur cette question merci très bien merci
la parole à Frédéric
Poussard merci monsieur le Président
merci Monsieur le le commissaire pour
ses propos introductifs alors je vais je
vais d'abord revenir aussi sur la
directive sur les plateformes si
certains se réjouissent d'autres peuvent
aussi s'inquiéter parce qu'on le sait
hein les plateformes vous l'avez dit
c'est un sujet qui est complexe mais
c'est un sujet qui aujourd'hui fait
quasiment travailler plus de 30 millions
de personnes au sein de l'Union
européenne et en l'occurrence cette
directive qui est discut
peut avoir un impact y compris sur la
pérennité des plateformes et et nous le
savons tous les uns les autres puisque
nous avons eu l'occasion de de de les
rencontrer même si elles sont de portées
différentes donc ma ma question sur le
sujet y a-t-il eu une étude d'impact
éventuellement de de cette de la mise en
en place de cette directive même si
j'imagine bien que ce que vous évoquez
peut effectivement laisser dans le flou
un certain nombre de de données
chiffrées et économique mais en tout cas
on ne peut pas s'empêcher de de penser
que la directive pourra avoir un impact
sur la vie d'un certain nombre de
plateformes donc voilà ma première
question la deuxième question qui qui a
trait au salaire minimum vous l'avez
développé je vous remercie des
informations que vous avez vous avez
précisé sous la président du du du
président mouiller nous avons fait le
choix d'ouvrir à la commission sociale
du Sénat une mission
d'information sur les négociations
collectives et en l'occurrence sur chez
nous les négociations Collectiv qui soiv
qui doivent suivre le rythme de
l'inflation avec un certain nombre de
difficultés vous l'avez évoqué vous-même
tous les pays ne sont pas dans ces
logique de négociation collective mais
est-ce que vous disposez d'une espèce de
de de de comparaison dans tous les pays
des difficultés qu'on pourrait
rencontrer précisément sur ces
mécanismes de négociation collective de
sorte que nous puissions éventuellement
en France avoir un certain nombre de
repères pour peut-être les fluidifier et
les simplifier de de façon à ce que en
l'occurrence en période de forte
inflation nous ne soyons pas toujours à
la course notamment sur les grilles de
bas salaire de
réactualisation
bien ça vous va par trois monsieur ça
vous répondz Didier Marie
fa merci président merci Monsieur le
Commissaire pour vos propos et en même
temps pour votre bilan parce que vous
n'aviez pas hérité de la mission la plus
simple au sein de la commission car
comme ça a été rappelé vous étiez sur un
certain nombre de sujets qui relevaient
pour partie voire en grande partie de la
compétence des États-membres et et la
recherche de compromis dans ce domaine
n'est pas toujours aisé euh on le
constate d'ailleurs aujourd'hui sur
cette question de la directive relative
au travailleurs des plateformes euh je
voudrais euh bon poser une question sur
le sujet
euh je sais que la négociation est en
cours la France a d'ailleurs demandé une
suspension de C Séan les travaux doivent
reprendre queépè à 16h30 donc tout ça
est en cours ceci étant parmi les
arguments que la France évoque il y a
ceux qui ne sont pas totalement assumés
qui consistent à dire qu'effectivement
les plateformes offrent beaucoup
d'emplois et qui serait dommage de les
mettre en difficulté ceci joant sur le
nombre de demandeur d'emploi et il y a
un autre argument concernant les effets
de cet accord
sur les accords collectifs nationaux
est-ce que vous pourriez nous donner
quelques éléments sur le sujet et nous
dire en quoi il y a ou pas difficultés
sur ces accords collectifs j'aurais une
deuxième question vous avez évoqué
précédemment la question de l'adéquation
entre les besoins de l'économie et
l'offre
d'emploi disponible euh la Commission a
a mis en place il y a quelques mois je
cite un un tinder dans l'emploi euh
est-ce que vous pourriez nous dire euh
quel est le premier bilan de de de cette
plateforme comment euh vous voyez à
l'avenir le rapprochement entre les
besoins euh de l'économie des
entreprises et euh cette capacité à
mettre en face euh les emplois et les
emplois avec les formations
correspondantes euh pour permettre à ces
entreprises de de de prospérer enfin
dernière question un peu décalé mais qui
est dans le registre de votre
portefeuille eu l'Union européenne a
accordé aux réfugiés ukrainien le statut
de protection temporaire ce qui a pour
conséquence de leur permettre pour un
grand nombre d'entre eux de travailler
est-ce que vous pouvez nous faire d'une
part un petit bilan du nombre de
personnes qui grâce à ce statut ont pu
accéder à des emplois et si ce sont des
emplois pérennes et comment ça
s'articule avec les problématiques
d'emploi des pays concerné je pense en
particulier à la Pologne et d'autre part
si ce statut sera pérenne tant que la
guerre durera et et quelles conséquen ça
peut avoir effectivement sur le marché
de l'emploi
européen je peux y aller ok merci
beaucoup encore quelques bon oui
brièvement sur la crise du logement
c'est c'est une c'est une crise
européenne du logement parce que je je
suis beaucoup en contact avec les villes
qui viennent me voir les régions
européennes et la plupart font part
effectivement de cette crise du logement
hein euh
elle a été un facteur important lors des
élections au Pays-Bas euh
elle j'ai eu récemment une visite de
villes européennes parmi la parmi
lesquelles il y avait une ville
française
lon mais aussi Barcelone mais aussi
Munich et toutes les villes me disent il
y a un problème de logement en Europe
avec des conséquences sociales
considérables avec des conséquences
d'inégalité considérables avec des
conséquences sur l'emploi considérable
donc c'est finalement une compétence qui
est plutôt nationale pour rester avec la
subsidiarité ou même parfois locale
parce que beaucoup de mairies ont la
compétence au niveau des logements
sociaux mais c'est devenu un problème
européen et donc il y a un appel ça je
le remarque il y a un appel de dire mais
qu'est-ce que l'Europe peut faire
comment est-ce que l'Europe peut
aider c'est pas la commission maintenant
qui va se mettre à construire des
logements
mais l'Europe peut
effectivement voir comment on peut aider
parce que la solution à la crise du
logement c'est la construction de
logement
c'est c'est la meilleure des solutions
en tout cas hein c'est la construction
de logement de logement d'ailleurs qui
pour la plupart des gens je parle pas
uniquement des gens avec les revenus les
plus bas parce qu'on est arrivé
maintenant à une situation où des gens
qui ont des des des des des revenus
correct n'arrivent plus à payer ou ont
beaucoup de mal à payer leur loyer ou
accéder à la à la à la
propriété on on voit aujourd'hui que
pour beaucoup de personnes le coût du
logement le coût du logement est arrivé
à 40 % de leur revenu 40 % par
simplement pour se loger et on est passé
en en en moins en 15 ans de autour de 20
un peu plus de 20 à 40 % ça c'est une
situation
sociale très dangereuse très
problématique mais c'est aussi
économiquement absolument absurde parce
que tout l'argent qui part dans le
logement peut pas êre peut pas partir
ailleurs peut pas être dépensé ailleurs
ça c'est le premier point donc ça une
incidence sur notre croissance sur notre
demande à l'échelle macro-économique
là-dessus aussi euh il y a un problème
de d'emploi parce que les gens qui
peuvent plus se se loger plus ou moins
près de leur emploi qui doivent faire
parfois des heures pour accéder à leur
emploi je crois que Paris c'est un bon
exemple malheureusement mais ce n'est
pas le seul donc il y a ce ce ce
problème alors qu'est-ce que l'Europe
peut faire on peut pas on peut
effectivement mobiliser plus de fonds
européens pour investir dans euh dans la
la construction de logement donc on est
en train de travailler là-dessus euh de
l'argent d'ailleurs qui est toujours
disponible dans le
fameux fond de résilience et de
relance certains États-membres ont pris
une partie de des fonds pour investir
dans le logement que j'appelle de
préférence abordable ça peut être du
social mais ça peut être aussi du
simplement du logement abordable ça
deuxièmement
moi je plaide beaucoup puisque on a ce
ce ce principe dans le socle pour
regarder nos nos nos mesures en terme de
de d'aide publique au logement pour les
assouplir un peu parce que ils sont
relativement limités juste
à à ce qu'on appelle le logement social
au sens de plus strict est-ce que il
faudrait pas peut-être assouplir un peu
pour là aussi permettre la construction
de logement dans ce
domaine troisièmement bien sûr il y a de
l'argent au niveau notamment de la
Banque européenne d'investissement je
sais que des projets sont financés mais
à à une échelle trop modeste pas la
Banque européenne d'investissement il y
a maintenant une nouvelle direction à la
Banque européenne d'investissement je
crois que cette nouvelle direction cette
nouvelle présidente a un autre regard
sur l'investissement et le financement
de tels projets donc voilà ce que
l'Europe peut contribuer
d'ailleurs j'aurai vendredi une réunion
sous présidence belge sur tout le le la
thématique du sansabrisme qui est la
forme la plus extrême du manque de
logement bien sûr avec plein d'autres
aspects sociaux et cetera donc on a
d'ailleurs lancé une plateforme pour
lutter contre le sansabrisme en Europe
il y a à peu près on sait pas exactement
mais 1 million de personnes sans abri en
Europe hein tendance croissante surtout
après le covid tendance fortement
croissante donc voilà un sujet que que
l'Europe doit traiter même si je suis
toujours d'accord que l'essentiel du
pouvoir réside près des pays enfin des
États-membres voire des
entités des entités régionales mais
c'est un grand sujet et comme je dis
c'est c'est c'est c'est un sujet
européen et je sens qu'il y a une
attente que l'Europe aussi se saisisse
un peu et soutiennent les États-membres
dans dans les politiques de logement sur
euh sur les plateforme il y a pas 30
millions il y en a un peu plus je crois
euh donc on a fait une bien sûr qu'on a
fait vous savez toute directive qui est
faite à l'échelle européenne est
précédée par de longues études d'impact
et on a fait une une étude d'impact et
on a trouvé que si on appliquait la
directive proposée par la Commission qui
n'est pas celle d'ailleurs qui est
maintenant dans la discussion au Conseil
voir dans le trilogue on
pouvait c'est pas de la science exact
hein mais on pouvait pense assumer enfin
l'hypothèse était que effectivement 5
millions de à l'échelle européenne hein
5 millions 5 millions et demi de
personnes travaillant pour les
plateformes seraient reclassifié donc ce
seraiit des personnes qui seraient pas
des indépendants mais seraient
effectivement des salariés alors vous
savez les plateforme c'est quelque chose
de très divers parce que quand on
discute de plateforme nous pensons tous
à uber pour pas les nommer hein qui sont
très actif d'ailleurs un peu partout moi
j'ai vu le PDG de Huber monsieur
américain plusieurs fois qui est venu
pleurer euh et et d'autres aussi mais
j'ai aussi des plateformes qui disent le
contraire donc il faut pas croire qu'il
y a que des plateformes qui disent il
faut rester avec l'indépendance il y a
des plateformes qui disent nous pour pas
les citer il y a une grande plateforme
de livreur qui s'appelle just it qui dit
moi je suis très mécontent s'il n'y a
pas de bonne directive parce que moi
j'emploie mes livreurs je leur donne euh
au moins le SMIC hein ou le salaire
minimum en vigueur où j'ai une
convention collective et donc c'est les
autres qui font de la concurrence
déloyale hein donc pensez que le la
reclassification au niveau des
plateformes voudrait dire on fait
disparaître les plateformes c'est faux
c'est faux parce que d'abord moi moi je
ne suis pas un défenseur par définition
des plateformes mais je vois évidemment
que que des millions de gens en Europe
chaque jour utilisent les plateformes je
ne parle pas des plateformes de travail
qui sont utilisé par Amazon et cetera
mais qui marche aussi qui emploie
occasionnellement des gens mais de plus
en plus y compris des gens de haute
qualification des architectes qui
travaillent sur les plateformes et
cetera mais je par là on parle surtout
des des euh des des plateformes
euh installé sur le le territoire et
donc si on donne un peu plus de droit
aux travailleurs de plateforme ça veut
pas dire que je ne vais plus
prendre une voiture uber mais peut-être
la répartition du prix sera autre entre
moi le consommateur la plateforme et le
la personne qui qui roule la même chose
vaut pour le livreur donc il y a là
besoin de voir quand même on se paye un
luxe c'est le transport ou la livraison
de la pizza à la maison ou autre chose B
il n'est pas quand même admissible que
quelqu'un pour que moi j'ai un service
et que la plateforme gagne de l'argent
quelqu'un en fait
souffre et payé au minimum absolu donc
je crois qu'il faut resturire par
ailleurs je dois dire c'est aussi un
élément de concurrence loyale ou
déloyale par rapport au taxi on le sait
par rapport aux
livraisons si vous vous avez maintenant
de plus en plus des livraisons de de
nourriture par exemple que vous pouvez
commander à la maison à la fin si c'est
tellement avantageux de faire livrer bah
les magasins ils peuvent fermer parce
que personne n'ira plus au magasin donc
et je crois et c'est de la concurrence
desloyales donc je crois que cette idée
que ça va détruire les plateformes
d'ailleurs la la preuve en Angleterre
uber a été condamné par une cour en
disant vous devez payer et cetera et
cetera est-ce que uber a disparu de
Londres non ils ont augmenté de 30 %
leurs effectifs à Londres donc je serais
très prudent euh là
euhdessus sur le oui bien sûr on a des
comparaisons comment fonctionne ça c'est
c'est c'est très ancré vous savez dans
les culture sociale des États-membres on
peut pas dire maintenant à partir de
demain la France va transposer le
système de de négociation de d'accords
collectifs de la Suède ou de l'Autriche
euh à la France donc ou ou à à la
Bulgarie hein donc il y a des
divergences très fortes d'ailleurs il y
a des pays qui sont très jaloux de leur
système qui le défendent bec et ongle on
voit ça en Suède maintenant avec masque
qui veut en fait casser le système de
d'accord collectif en Suède et et il y a
une réaction forte des syndicats et donc
je crois que c'est utile d'aller voir
quels sont les modèles est-ce qu'on peut
ajuster notre modèle pour le pour le
rendre plus efficace notamment pour
répondre à ce que vous dites sur
l'inflation pour ajuster plus rapidement
et plus euh je dirais euh de façon plus
appropriée les euh les euh les salaires
sur euh
euh les euh réfugiés euh
oui globalement un succès je dirais il y
a plus d'un million de personnes qui ont
trouvé un emploi globalement à l'échelle
européenne euh c'était la bonne manière
je crois d'avoir se mettre en œuvre la
directive sur la protection temporaire
qui prendra fin l'année prochaine on ne
sait pas pour le moment quelle sera la
suite je peux pas vous le dire c'est il
y a il y a un point il y a un point
d'interrogation il faut trouver une
solution parce que la guerre
malheureusement je suis pas sûr si elle
a va être terminée l'année prochaine
donc il y a toujours si je me rappelle
bien autour de 5 millions de réfugiés un
peu partout en Europe et avec un pays
qui a été mentionné la Pologne a assez
bien géré la situation assez bien géré
parce qu'ils sont bien sûr en première
ligne ils nont pas reçu tous he le pays
qui en a reçu le plus c'est quand même
l'Allemagne hein bon c'est quand même
l'Allemagne qui en a reçu le plus mais
proportionnellement c'est à Tchéquie qui
en a reçu le le niveau le plus élevé je
crois que c'est globalement ça a été
bien bien réussi ce qui maintenant se
pose c'est que sous souvent les
Ukrainiens qui sont en général des
ukrainiennes parce que la plupart des
personnes qui sont venues sont des
femmes bon travaille largement en
dessous de leur niveau de qualification
et là on travaille comme ça a été dit
sur des comparaisons et pour mieux
ajuster les les les les les
qualifications qui sont en Europe chez
nous dans l'Union et les qualifications
ukrainiennes donc on essaie d'aligner et
de comparer de voir qui est
effectivement comparable entre les deux
donc ça c'est je dirais un aspect un
aspect ant voilà merci beaucoup Monsieur
le Commissaire je vais donner maintenant
la parole à Pascal gruni
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Commissaire moi je suis à la fois à
la commission des affaires sociales et à
la commission des affaires européennes
et je suis l'Europe social avec des
d'autres collègues alors d'abord une
question un peu un peu globale parce que
quand on vous écoute on voit bien que
les initiatives sociales majeures comme
la plateforme les règlements sécurité
sociale ben on naboutit pas très très
vite voire même c'est très très long
donc ma question c'est comment on peut
surmonter en fait les lignes de fracture
entre
États-membres qui sont le reflet de la
diversité des modèles sociaux donc
est-ce qu'il faut pas réviser les les
traités pour justement essayer
d'apporter des des réponses parce que ça
ça devient des
blocages moi j'avais une question aussi
sur la
pauvreté parce que un des objectif du
plan d'action socle européen des droits
sociaux c'est la réduction d'au moins 15
millions du nombre de personnes menacées
de pauvreté et au moins 5 millions
d'enfants et or on voit que le taux de
pauvreté n'a pas reculé et il a même
augmenté donc je sais pas où vous en
êtes la carte européenne du du handicap
cap parce que ça c'est quelque chose qui
est aussi attendu
concernant notamment le stationnement
aussi pour les personnes handicapées et
globalement sur sur le le handicap
quelles ont été les avancées par la
Commission européenne depuis
2019 et puis le nouveau sommet social
qui devrait se tenir à La Hulpe est-ce
que vous avez quelque chose à nous dire
sur les priorités de la commission je
vous
remercie
merci Karine Daniel et s prépare mathil
d'Olivier merci monessieurs les
présidents chers collègues merci d'abord
Monsieur le Commissaire d'avoir partagé
avec nous vos vos actions sur votre
champ de de compétence au sein de de
l'Union européenne alors en effet
l'emploi et les droits sociaux sont des
responsabilités cruciales pour garantir
la dignité le bien-être des populations
et la protection des travailleurs au
sein de l'Union et participe à l'Europe
sociale et désirable à laquelle nous
aspirons dans le contexte actuel marqué
par des défis tels que la mondialisation
l'automatisation vous en avez parlé avec
les combats que que vous menez sur le
sujet des plateformes mais demain
l'intelligence artificielle qui vont
aussi bousculer le le monde du travail
la crise écologiques et les changements
démographiques il est crucial de
renforcer l'Europe sociale en
investissant dans l'éducation la
formation professionnelle et la
recherche nous pouvons préparer nos nos
concitoyens aux emplois de demain et
leur offrir des Opport opportunité de
développement personnel et professionnel
malgré de nombreux efforts et vous en
avez parlé et parfois même des succès la
dimension sociale de la construction
européenne demeure le pilier fragile ou
un pilier fragile des politiques
européennes pourtant il n'a jamais été
aussi urgent d'agir efficacement contre
la précarité au travail d'améliorer les
conditions de travail de réussir les
transitions écologique et et numérique
pour réduire les inégalités la crise
agricole actuelle à appelle plus que
jamais à à muscler les mutations
écologiques déployées à travers les
politiques européennes et à les
compléter par un Green Deal social qui
permettent de garantir des politiques
d'accompagnement social ça doit être une
des priorités de la prochaine mandature
cependant pour que l'Europe sociale
devienne une réalité concrète il est
nécessaire de renforcer la coordination
et la coopération entre les
États-membres vous l'avez dit et nous
devons travailler ensemble pour
harmoniser les systèmes de protection
sociale promouvoir des norme de travail
équitable et garantir des conditions de
travail décentes pour toutes et tous
j'emploie le terme de norme à dessin
puisque notre travail dans la
construction européenne c'est de
construire ces normes de travail ces
normes sociales ces normes
environnementales et on voit qu'à chaque
crise il est de bon temps de de taper
sur ces normes et on l'a encore vu
récemment donc moi j'appelle de mes vœux
et et je je vous demande dans quelle
mesure
on doit prendre notre notre porte-voie
pour dire et redire que le progrès en
Europe il passe par la construction de
normes et notamment par la construction
de normes sociales quelles sont nos
marges de manœuvre dans ce domaine merci
de votre
attention la parole la parole à Corine
FERR pardon ma Olivier pardon ex
queuse-moi j'avis
pas merci merci messieur le président et
euh merci Monsieur le Commissaire je
souhaitais revenir encore sur la
directive européenne sur la protection
des travailleurs des plateformes alors
elle n'était pas elle n'est pas parfaite
mais ça représente quand même une
opportunité historique puisque c'est
quand même la première fois que la
Commission européenne se pche sur le
sujet et ça permettrait d'améliorer
fortement euh les conditions de travail
des 5 millions de travailleurs de ces
plateforme en Europe où les 30 euh vous
le disiez vous-même l'enjeu et que la
création d' emplois des plateformes
numériques puissent être des emplois de
qualité et de pas laisser les
travailleurs dans la précarité euh on
sait ce qui blo vous en avez parlé c'est
la présomption euh avec le lobbying
quand même intense de la France pour
limiter le caractère prescriptif du
dossier et aussi la protection de
l'autonomie totale des autorités
nationales compétentes sur la
présempption légal euh mais si vous nous
pouviez nous donner plus d'informations
sans vous avancer sur les négociations
en cours sur les différentes options qui
sont aujourd'hui sur la table pour
arriver à un compromis euh et puis si ce
compromis passe le Parlement parlait de
couper la directive en deux afin que
qu'un accord puisse être trouvé sur la
gestion algorithmique euh et de laisser
la question de la présomption légale
pour après les élections de juin est-ce
que vous pouvez nous dire si on s'est
maintenant plutôt éloigné de cette
option ou si elle est toujours sur la
table et puis juste un commentaire aussi
sur les indemnités chômage et sur la
l'harmonisation au niveau européen je
représente les Français de
l'étranger et c'est un sujet qui revient
assez régulièrement que celui du
transfert des droits de chômage
lorsqu'on change d'un pays à l'autre
lorsque par exemple un couple change de
enfin déménage d'un pays à l'autre que
l'un des des l'une des personnes quitte
son emploi arrive dans un nouveau pays
et peut demander dans l'Union européenne
ces droits de chômage le transfert de
ces droits de chômage mais avec des
difficultés administratives qui sont
très importante pour pouvoir avoir
accéder à ces droits pour pouvoir
accéder à ces droits avec un nombre de
formulaires demandés d'un côté de
l'autre euh et puis la plupart du temps
les services en charge de de gérer ces
questions euh de chômage euh qui ne sont
pas informés de la manière dont dont les
personnes peuvent toucher leur droit de
chômage donc est-ce que vous avez une
perspective là-dessus et sur les
perspectives d'évolution euh de ces de
ces indemnité chômage et de
l'harmonisation au niveau européen
merci OK
voilà peut-être un un mot sur sur la
pauvreté qui qui est réelle et vous avez
cité les 95 millions d'Européens qui
sont pas qui sont dans un risque de
pauvreté mais souvent malheureusement
pour beaucoup ce risque se matérialise
hein et et se concrétise donc en fait on
a fixé effectivement un objectif de
réduire ce nombre de 15 millions dont 5
millions d'enfants et bon il appartient
bien sûr aux États-membres aussi de
s'engager là-dessus puisque chaque
état-membre a présenté un objectif je me
rappelle plus exactement l'objectif de
la France mais chaque étatmembre a
présenté un objectif et l'addition
d'ailleurs de ces objectifs nous
rapproche des 15 millions voilà donc ça
c'est l'aspect la politique qu'est-ce
que l'Europe elle-même elle fait bien
sûr elle fait à travers le fond social
européen puisque c'it une question elle
alloue euh un certain nombre de fonds à
euh à promouvoir l'inclusion elle alloue
des fonds aux différents acteurs qui
luttent contre la pauvreté en France
laabé piierre par exemple est largement
aussi financé par euh le fond social
européen puisque avant ça s'appelait le
féad qui a été intégré dans le le Fond
Social Européen donc euh on a adopté une
recommandation sur euh le le salaire le
sur le revenu minimum donc avec un
certain nombre de de principes comment
on prescrit pas comment dans chaque État
de quel montant et ceera mais quels sont
les éléments les principes qui devraient
guider la politique en matière de revenu
minimum et on a adopté puisque vous avez
cité aussi les enfants une garantie pour
l'enfance parce que on sait très bien
que malheureusement la pauvreté se
transmet hein on hérite souvent de la
pauvreté s'il y a rien à hériter la
pauvreté on l'hérite donc c'est un une
une politique je
dirais holistique globale de lutte
contre la pauvreté au niveau des enfants
bon bien sûr il faut jamais négliger les
familles parce que quand vous avez un
enfant pauvre il vient rarement d'une
famille riche donc il faut bien sûr agir
sur sur les familles sur le logement sur
le travail sur l'insertion dans le
travail sur les maires souvent les
parents
euh pardon monoparental voilà souvent
par exemple le nombre de de de de
ménages
monoparentaux majorité 75 % des femmes
sont souvent exposées à ce risque parce
que les femmes ne peuvent pas travailler
elles doivent parce qu'elles ne trouvent
pas de de crèche et cetera donc tout
cela c'est une politique qu'on essaie de
mettre dans d'inciter les états mem à
mettre en œuvre toujours selon leur
propre système on a une coordination
entre États-membres toujours dans
l'esprit de subsidiarité et on espère
que à travers ces politiques on peut
agir contre la pauvreté je crois que
c'est c'est essentiel pour moi
d'ailleurs puisque quelqu'un m'a dit
quelle doit être pour La Hulpe un des un
des thèmes cent Trux c'est l'inclusion
et la lutte contre la pauvreté c'est
l'inclusion et la lutte contre la
pauvreté parce que elle est mauvaise
d'un point de vue social elle divise de
plus en plus nos sociétés et euh elle
est d'ailleurs aussi mauvaise d'un point
de vue purement économique si nous nous
plaignons aujourd'hui de la pénurie de
main-dœuvre si on donne pas les chances
à des jeunes à des familles à des femmes
de travailler d'acquérir des formations
et cetera ben on va pas résoudre le
problème de la pénurie de main d'ovvre
en partie du moins donc je crois que
c'est un des un des thèmes centraux sur
la carte handicap oui elle a été adoptée
maintenant sous
présidence sous la présidence espagnole
elle va être maintenant mise en œuvre il
y a d'ailleurs deux cartes parce que
pour des raisons de compéten il y a une
carte qui couvre un certain nombre de
situations sociales et l'autre par
exemple le le le stationnement c'est une
autre carte mais ça c'est je crois un
instrument très pratique qui montre que
l'Europe peut faire quelque chose de
positif pour la vie quotidienne de
certaines personnes qui sont déjà
suffisamment en difficulté et d'ailleurs
on a lancé une stratégie pour les
personnes avec handicap
ou précisément on a mis au cœur de cela
aussi l'emploi l'insertion encourager
les entreprises à employer les personnes
avec handicap moi j'été longtemps
ministre du Travail j'ai j'ai noté que
il y a une énorme discrimination une
méfiance à l'égard des personnes avec
handicap et quand quelqu'un emploie une
personne l'emplo l'employeur souvent
découvre que cette personne est plus
efficace plus productive et plus motivé
que que que quiconque donc je crois
qu'il faut continuer à travailler sur ce
ce ce sujet du absolument du handicap
voilà donc
l'inclusion au sens large du terme la
lutte contre la pauvreté et bien sûr et
je passe à d'autres questions le monde
du travail de
l'avenir effectivement le monde du
travail est en parfaite évolution
ébulion je dirais à la fois euh du fait
des technologies dont j'ai déjà parlé
l'intelligence artificielle est en en
train de s'étendre donc il faut prendre
la mesure de l'impact à ces nouvelles
technologies sur la qualité du travail
sur la formation nécessaire pour euh
permettre à à à à à maximum de de de
travailleurs mais aussi aussi des
citoyens puisque nous sommes également
concernés comme citoyens par l'extension
des nouvelles technologies que ce soit
au niveau de nos opérations bancaires et
cetera donc de de veiller à ce que on va
pas avoir cette division numérique au
sein de notre société où des gens savent
et d'autres ne savent pas et donc de de
ce fait de ne pas savoir utiliser les
instruments numérique ils se ils se
marginalisent et ils sont exclus donc je
crois que c'est c'est un grand sujet
bien sûr sur le travail sur la qualité
du travail on a eu un sous présidence
suédoise un un une sorte de sommet sur
les conditions de travail sur la
sécurité et la santé au travail cette
commission a fait plusieurs grands
projets je crois qu'il y en a CIN sur
des substances dangereuses parce que les
les gens qui deviennent malades à leur
poste de
travail c'est
c'est c'est la réalité toujours hier non
aujourd'hui le Parlement j'espère j'ai
pas regardé mais devait adopter par
exemple une nouvelle directive un
amendement pour inclure le plomb le
plomb
dans la
définition jusqu'à quel niveau quels
sont les les le niveau d'exposition d'un
travailleur au plomb hein et donc il
faut vérifier si parce que on sait très
bien que le plomb est dangereux
cancérigène et surtout très dangereux
aussi pour les femmes notamment les
femmes éventuellement enceintes ou qui
qui peut-être seront enceintes donc je
crois que c'est un sujet très important
sur la protection de la santé la
sécurité au travail pour moi un grand
acquis c'est la directive
sur sur la miantee bon on sait que la
miantee a fait des ravages dans tous les
états continue à faire des ravages on a
pris une directive d'ailleurs on attend
une nouvelle directive d'un autre
commissaire sur les bâtiments et la
construction et donc protéger mieux les
travailleurs sur la miante avec les
parce que maintenant on rénove beaucoup
de bâtiments notamment des bâtiments
anciens et dans beaucoup de bâtiments il
y a laamante donc bien sûr les
conditions de travail encore une fois si
l'Europe manque de bras si l'Europe
manque de
travailleurs ça veut dire qu'il faut
mieux protéger les travailleurs qu'on a
faut pas rendre les gens malades et là
je suis très explicite on peut pas
demander et et je ne je ne discute pas
l'objectif on peut pas demander aux gens
de travailler plus longtemps pour des
raisons démographiqu pour des raisons de
financement de la sécurité sociale des
régimes je ne discute pas si c'est juste
ou pas je veux pas me mêler de ça mais
on peut pas le demander si on n'agit pas
de de façon très conséquente sur la
qualité du travail sur les conditions de
travail sur la santé au travail si
quelqu'un et
et voit sa santé ruinée à 56 ans parce
que effectivement il a il a subi des
conditions de travail impossible peut
pas lui demander de travailler jusqu'à
je ne sais pas 67 ans pour pour citer
des pays qui qui remonte l'âge de la
retraite à cet âge làà donc je crois
qu'il y a un intérêt à à modifier
les conditions de travail absolument
partout parce que d'abord c'est dans
l'intérêt de tous c'est dans inérêt des
travailleurs mais c'est à la fois aussi
dans l'intérêt de nos sociétés bon sur
les plateformes c'est c'est tout ce qui
est le cœur même c'est cette fameuse
présemption bon j'ai dit auparavant la
présempption ne dit pas automatiquement
tout le monde est un travailleur est un
salarié mais il s'agit de faciliter la
définition et la la définition
effectivement à quelle catégorie cette
personne appartient est-ce que c'est un
salarié doit être classé comme salarié
ou est-ce que effectivement cette
personne est un est un un un
indépendant donc c'est c'est ça et c'est
cela qui est
débattu avec les critères est-ce qu'il
faut des critères européens ce que avait
proposé la commission maintenant on est
revenu là-dessus on dit bon ok c'est les
critères nationaux il y a des états qui
ont peur encore davantage que finalement
leur système soit mis en cause par
l'application de la présempption puisque
ils ont créé une sorte 3è catégorie sans
trop le dire parce que il y a pas de
définition claire du salarié ou du
travailleur donc c'est un débat très
difficile à ce niveau mais important
parce que comme le statut entraîne les
droits si vous si vous avez un statut de
salarié vous avez des droits si vous
voyez un statut d'indépendant vous
n'avez pas exactement les mêmes droits
donc il y a il y a un débat très très
ponctuel et très très ciblé sur sur ces
divisé en deux je suis pas très pour
hein je crois que c'est un tout c'est à
la fois le statut et la protection
algorithmique et bon sur les droits du
chômage moi je viens d'un pays où il y a
beaucoup de frontaliers j'ai beaucoup
discuté avec les frontaliers et
paradoxalement les frontaliers était
contre une régulation européenne donc
ils m'ont toujours dit moi je préfère
aller à l'époque ça s'appelait pour
l'emploi maintenant çaappelle France
travail je crois je préfère aller là
parce que je connais je parle la langue
et je veux pas aller en Allemagne être
classé et ce donc il y a un sujet donc
c'est pas uniquement il y a aussi des
frontaliers notamment qui veulent bon
vous citez un autre cas c'est quand je
déménage et je vais dans un autre pays
normalement j'ai le droit de garder m
mes droits au chômage pendant 3 mois ça
ça devrait être consolidé maintenant le
problème c'est que parfois on accuse
l'Europe d'être compliqué d'imposer des
charges administratives qui sont en fait
des charges administratives imposées par
les États-membres et donc moi je dis si
je déménage je vais ailleurs pour des
raisons qui correspondent tout à fait à
mes droits c'est aux États-membres de
facilité de simplifier les chares
administratives c'est pas la commission
qui contrôle qui bouge d'un pays a au
pays B c'est aux étatsmembres et là je
suis très tout à fait d'accord avec
monsieur le Président faut être très
subsidiaire c'est aux États-membres de
simplifier les les les charges
administratives merci beaucoup on
continue avec Corine
FERR merci monsieur le Président je suis
donc sénatrice du calvado c'est membre
de la commission des affaires sociales
et je voulais vous interroger sur un je
dirais une autre un autre sujet mais qui
nous impacte tous qui est celui du
changement climatique lequel changement
climatique a un fort impact sur les
conditions de travail des Européens et
je voulais savoir quels sont ou quels
seraient les chantiers de la Commission
européenne pour amener une évolution des
droits du travail au sein de l'Union
européenne afin de garantir le respect
des droits fondamentaux des travailleurs
notamment celui d'exercer leur activité
professionnelle dans des conditions qui
ne soient pas dommageables à leur santé
et également dans le respect du droit de
chacun à accéder à un
emploi merci alors
j'aijin prépare
maraidra on
va d'accord
oui je tiens à remercier les présidents
car je suis un intru ici je suis de la
commission du développement durable et
je suis en même temps sénateur de et
donc voisin de par que la schmi on se
connaît bien maintenant et j'ai été
amené à travailler sur les travailleurs
de plateforme par le biais de la loi
d'orientation des mobilités dans
laquelle il y avait trois articles sur
le sujet je me suis passionné sur cette
question et déposé plusieurs PPL dont la
première en Europe qui parlait de
requalification avant même l'Espagne qui
avait été déposé le 4 mars 2021 pilepoil
un an après l'arrêt de la Cour de
cassation fameux du 4 mars 2020 qui
parlait des indépendants fictifs
s'agissant de travailleurs de plateforme
moi je tiens vraiment à saluer ton
travail particulièrement sur le salaire
minimum et les tentative sur les
travailleurs de plateforme en cours
c'est l'Europe qu'on aime c'est l'Europe
au secours euh des travailleurs de
plateforme c'est l'Europe sociale je
tiens à dire à ma collègue Frédéric
puissac que sur l'ubérisation par
exemple à Paris on a une sociologue euh
laéticia lablanc qui travaille qui
travaille précisément là-dessus elle
estime que actuellement
chez les livreurs à vélo il y a 90 % de
travailleurs en situation irrégulière
soit qu'ils utilisent un faux compte
pour se connecter soit qu'il n'ont pas
les papiers d'identité et les cartes de
travail satisfaisantes avec des
rémunérations qui atteignent 5 € de
l'heure voire moins en final après
rémunération du sous-traitant
illégal loueur de compte euh je voulais
poser une question unique mais tu y as
déjà parfaitement répondu à savoir si
les PL quelle plateforme quel type de
plateforme seraiit menacé je tiens à
préciser aussi à ma collègue Frédéric
puissa que justit vient d'annoncer en
France qu'elle renonçait à salari des
livreurs à vélo en septembre elle aura
licencié tout le monde parce qu'elle est
en distorsion de concurrence par rapport
aux plateformes qui travaillent dans ces
situations d'illégalité donc ma question
unique Nicolas pour ne pas abuser de du
temps de tout le monde c'est l'impact
éventuel d'une dérogation qui serait
donné à la France on sait que la France
est le plus grand obstacle actuellement
à ton projet de directive jusqu'où
peut-on aller pour dans le cadre d'une
Union européenne pour admettre que
certains pays traitent le la question de
manière différente et donc la France on
tu l'as dit elle cherche à imposer un
tiers statut je vous remercie beaucoup
et vous remercie encore et oui merci on
passera le massage à fréric puissant
alors maintenant la parole à Martha
deidrac
merci Messieurs les Présidents Monsieur
le
Commissaire vous avez évoqué dans vos
propos les nites en France parce que
vous sembliez vous ne pas tout à fait
être sûr si nous en avons en France nous
en avons évidemment vous vous en doutez
bien on pas loin de 1 million de nit
aujourd'hui en France qui sont des
jeunes de 16 à 25 ans et qui sont
souvent accompagnés par un réseau de
mission local dans nos territoires ma
question va porter sur les jeunes
justement et
l'Europe il se trouve que les missions
locales parfois font appel également à
l'Europe à travers les dispositifs
d'Erasmus plus plus qui sont des
dispositifs et des mesures qui existent
au bénéfice de ces jeunes et qui sont
souvent portés là encore dans les
territoires qui on non par des centres
d'Europe direct ou des maisons de
l'Europe en fait que l'on peut avoir
partout en Europe en revanche ce qui est
très compliqué d'un point de vue
opérationnel c'est comment faire
bénéficier plus aisément un le plus
grand nombre de nos jeunes dans nos
territoires qui soit nit ou pasite
d'ailleurs a des dispositifs
d'échange de formation et de travail
entre Européens parce que aujourd'hui
tous ces dispositifs existent mais je
vous assure quand vous devez remplir un
dossier qui est des qui concurrence un
livre de la playéade par moment c'est
très décourageant donc tout le monde se
gargarise de simplification mais
l'Europe ferait bien aussi de simplifier
éleion merci bien merci beaucoup pour
ces dernières question sur le changement
climatique effectivement ça transforme
beaucoup de métiers parce que notamment
les les grandes chaleurs et on a vous
savez une agence qui
s'appellea donc c'est l'agence Bilbao
qui s'occupe de la sécurité de la santé
au travail et elle aim un certain nombre
de de de recommandations de de de lignes
directrices sur des problèmes comme par
exemple le travail lors des grande
chaleur donc voilà un aspect qui est
devenu beaucoup plus réel même dans les
parties plus nord du Nord septentrional
de l'Europe parce qu'avant c'était
plutôt le sud mais maintenant aussi les
grandes chaleurs ça affecte aussi donc
voilà ce qu'on comment on opère avec des
lignes directrices en s'adaptant au
contrat notamment du changement
climatique ça ça la construction mais
l'agriculture si vous êtes du
oui du Calvados donc la la viticulture
je crois non pas du tout c'est c'est le
c'est voilà ouais vous travaillez avec
les les raisins des autres vous
fabriquez surtout du du cognac non non
c'est chez moi plutôt chez
vous ah les pommes oui c'est c'est la
Normandie la Normandie oui c'est la
sidre j'ai j'ai
confondu donc tout tout ce qui est
agriculture et et et et les fruits et
cetera donc je crois qu'il y a besoin
aussi notamment de couvrir des secteurs
comme
l'agriculture par ces ces lignes
directrices pour protéger les
travailleurs donc ça c'est c'est ce que
l'Europe peut contribuer après c'est
bien sûr l'application sur le terrain et
ça c'est encore une fois au niveau des
États-membres que ça doit être fait euh
oui j'ai confendu Conac euh voilà euh
sur sur les euh sur la la question sur
les la mobilité les les jeunes bon
l'Europe a a beaucoup d'initiatives
notamment de mobilité des des jeunes euh
avec un projet comme Alma qui permet à
des jeunes sans qualification et cetera
aussi d'avoir une expérience de travail
à l'extérieur dans un autre pays moi
j'avoue j'aiai jamais vu les euh les
documents qu'il faut euh qu'il faut
remplir j'ai vu des jeunes qui l'ont
fait ils m'ont pas parlé de ça mais
probablement c'est juste ils avaient
quelqu'un qui a rempli les papiers pour
eux euh je crois que c'est un des grands
sujets en général j'ai dit c'est sujet à
à la fois au niveau national mais c'est
aussi le le sujet au niveau européen je
prends votre remarque et je vais
m'intéresser à toute la production de
papier et de remplir des dossiers pour
avoir ça la même chose vaut pour Erasmus
d'ailleurs on veut beaucoup promouvoir
maintenant Erasmus non seulement pour
les étudiants puce que là ça sble marché
ils y arrivent donc probablement mieux à
remplir mais surtout pour les apprentis
donc la mobilité pour les apprentis
d'ailleurs il y a un ancien député
ancien ministre français qui s'investit
beaucoup là-dedans et donc on on
soutient beaucoup cette mobilité des
jeunes à ce niveau sur les jeunes sur
les ns je crois que c'est un chantier
qu'il faut vraiment développer et c'est
à la fois les méthodes de formation de
requalification on va pas arriver des
jeunes qui ont quitté l'école pour
quelque raison que ce soit S souvent
pour des raisons personnelles et cetera
on va pas automatiquement les
renvoyer dans une classe donc il faut
trouver des
méthodes il faut peut-être développer
l'apprentissage pour ces jeunesl il faut
trouver les bonnes méthodes pour leur
donner une formation qui leur permet
après l'insertion sur le marché du
travail et ça il est vrai l'Europe a
puisque s'il y a dans le fond social
vous m'avez demandé il y a même une
obligation d' tir au moins si je me
rappelle bien 7 % des fonds que qui est
qui qui sont alloués à aux États-membres
minimum mais au-delà d'un certain seuil
ça va autour de 12 je crois dans
l'emploi des jeunes et notamment avec
une concentration sur uneits et là il
est clair aussi et ça c'est un autre
aspect il faut travailler avec les
territoires il faut travailler là où les
jeunes sont il faut essayer de à la fois
organiser des formations je connais bien
l'école la deuxème chance par exemple
euh il faut promouvoir des méthodes d'
de de de rattrapage des de ces jeunes
pour qu'il retrouvent le goût aussi
d'apprendre d'apprendre un métier
d'apprendre euh d'apprendre un métier
pour effectivement s'insérer donc je
crois que ça c'est euh absolument euh
important euh parce que là on a s'il y a
1 million de jeunes qui sont en dehors
ben ce sont les les jeunes dont
l'économie aurait besoin hein donc il
faut bien sûr les former faut leur
donner le goût du travail aussi
l'intérêt pour après les insérer dans un
emploi correct et non pas précaire parce
que ça c'est l'autre aspect trop de
jeunes on fait l'expérience d'emploi
précaire c'est effectivement les
plateformes mais pas uniquement mais ça
peut être le cas donc je crois que c'est
c'est un grand chantier mon dernier bien
dernière remarque c'est effectivement
les plateformes et les l'emploi de
personnes qui sont par exemple
en qui sont pas régularisé qui n'ont pas
normalement un un une autorisation de
travail la directive que qui est en
discussion a aussi un volet sur les
intermédiaires parce que il y a une
pratique de plus en plus fréquente
d'utiliser des intermédiaires donc la
plateforme elle se décharge de tout il y
a on crée une sorte intermédiaire et
c'est l'intermédiaire qui est en
relation et là il y a des dispositions
pour encadrer aussi les intermédiaire et
arriver aussi à une reclassification
quand il s'agit de d'intermédiaire voilà
et je m'excuse encore une fois pour
avoir confondu calvatos et le
cogac
impardonnable impardonnable les deux
sont bons mais c'est
et en tous les cas pour les deux à
consommer avec modération tout à fait
c'est aussi une question de santé au
travail
merci beaucoup Monsieur le Commissaire
pour vos réponses précises et et
intéressantes qui qui nous amène à
continuer ces travaux sur l'Europe
sociale et qui nous éclaire merci merci
beaucoup pour l'invitation et
l'échangeour très intéressant merci
beaucoup
strasbourgasbour
merci